This video is brought to you by news voice, the news.
As broken almost all us media is owned by just a handful of big corporations.
Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something unbiased can be difficult.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeeds by aggregating major news
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each news story shows multiple sources,
which are all times with our bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives. What we hear on re shapes,
which people we trust, what we eat, what we buy, how we vote,
even how we think news voice is greeted by its readers.
As you can avoid stories that you find interesting.
So more people will see them as essentially a democratized platform for news
plus saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources and one app so that you can be better
informed and it's totally free, which I approve of as I'm Scottish.
And we don't like spending money. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and the app store. Anyway, let's get correct.
Okay.
I asked you to tell me three things,
three things about this country without consulting, Google,
what would you come up with? One is easy to may be possible, but for three,
my guess is that most of you would be struggling. Am I wrong? And quite frankly,
it's not surprising.
Bhutan is one of the least known and most isolated countries in the world.
Not only geographically, but also, and most importantly,
politically and commercially be honest. Have you ever really thought about it?
How does things work in this country? What does Butan produce? Who's in charge.
Yeah.
And there's a small kingdom located in the very heart of the Himalayas.
It's very similar in size to Switzerland.
And like Switzerland is also a very mountainous nation. However,
that's sort of where the similarities end with a population 10 times smaller
than Switzerland and the level of development that places that among the poorest
countries and the world Bhutan is a kind of Herrmann kingdom that was completely
closed until just a few years ago. Its greatest international achievement. Well,
according to its government being the happiest.
Three in the world.
That's not something that we're completely sure about in this video.
We'll go into Bhutan. We'll talk about it. Society, economy,
and political system. And not only that,
we're also going to tell you some things that you probably would never have
associated with a police. That's supposed to be the happiest nation on earth.
Are you coming to Bhutan with us? Let's get started then.
Tan reasons to be happy.
We've done as a country with such pure air that it could almost be sold in a
can, which let's be honest we might need to do in the future.
I'm not because it's one of the most environmentally intact and best preserved
countries on the planet to give you an idea.
Almost three quarters of the country is covered in forests.
And 60% of the national territory has been declared as protected areas.
This includes a natural park, the sack Tang wildlife sanctuary,
which was basically created for the preservation of the MICU, the Yeti,
the abominable snowman. No,
really the greats is a national park for the Yeti Scotland,
making a national park for Nassi was that we did that really that's right
though. And this country, they take tradition very, very seriously.
In other words, Bhutan is something of a Relic from another era,
a natural paradise in which tourism was not allowed until 1974,
which is coincidentally the ear where the shirt comes from. And even today,
if you want to visit,
let's just say that tourism here is very different from anywhere else.
You see tourists who arrive in the country in addition to transport,
have to pay a daily fee, ranging from a range 200 to $290. However,
this rate acts as a kind of flat rate, it includes a gate, your hotel and food.
And other words,
the only way to visit this country is to book a tourist package through the
government.
It's kind of strange when you think perhaps this is one of the reasons why there
are just over 270,000 tourists who visited every year
In case my visual politics runs without a doubt.
The most characteristic element of Bhutan has nothing to do with either
tourists, hikers or anything like that.
But with a political innovation that launched its government almost five days.
Cool.
In 1972, as a way to overcome criticism about the country's high poverty rates.
And at the same time, trying to reconcile with the modern world,
the particular traditional lifestyle of Britain, the then King of this country,
[inaudible] proposed a new way to measure progress and general wellbeing.
It was a shift in focus from gross domestic product to something known as the
gross national happiness index,
a new indicator that takes into account things like psychological wellbeing,
community relations, health access to education,
or how you use your time that as this new indicator seeks to compliment the
material aspects of progress with the most spiritual and psychological part of
the human being that's at least was.
Of course.
Having said that a lot of people may be thinking, Oh,
so this is kind of interesting. So Bhutan is a world leader in happiness. Well,
no, the truth is it's not at all, not even within its own index,
either that Malian kingdom is nowhere near the top.
According to the 2019 world happiness report,
which the United nations initiative called the sustainable development solutions
network and which presents annually, Bhutan is not even in the top 10, nor 20.
It's not even in the top 50 happiest countries in the world.
It ranks all the way down and 95th place just above Cameroon.
A possession does not seem to be in line with this image of being one of the
happiest countries in the world,
nor with the apparent importance they place on this very concept.
So.
It's kind of surprising when you think, by the way, here's a question,
which countries do you think are the happiest,
according to this curious indicator? Well,
the ranking is led by countries like Finland, Denmark, Switzerland, New Zealand,
Canada, Israel, Poland. That is,
it turns out that this particular ranking of gross happiness is closely related
to the rates of prosperity, economic and wealth per capita. In other words,
the retro country is sooner or later,
it also tends to reap better results in terms of happiness.
Are you surprised because you really shouldn't be, but that's for another time,
let's not get distracted. As we said, even in this ranking of gross happiness,
Bhutan is found in a possession as low as 95th. So in other words,
they've kind of messed up haven't they?
Because almost every time we see in the press news-related to this index,
it always seems that Bhutan is the happiest country in the world.
And as you see, it's not even close, not by a long way.
So now the question we have to ask ourselves is why is Bhutan really such an
unhappy.
Country?
You see,
even if this country has managed to double its life expectancy in the last 20
years and is able to put almost 100% of children in primary education,
the truth is that things are not exactly going well today.
A quarter of the nearly 800,000 Bhutanese survive on less than $1 and
25 cents a day,
which is the amount that is considered to be the extreme poverty threshold.
This is why Bhutan always appears on the list of least developed countries that
the UN prepares each year.
Yeah.
No, only that, although we are talking about a relatively calm country,
violent crimes have increased and street gangs on the trafficking of goods for
food for sale on the black market are becoming more frequent to top.
All this off climate change is also affecting a country.
I simply not been prepared for it.
[Inaudible].
As you can imagine,
the change in weather patterns has become a problem in a country that remains
very, very dependent on nature,
a country where industry is virtually non-existent and we're 70% of the
population are small holder farmers.
The fact that less and less snow and rainfall,
or that they fall more irregularly causes many crops to be lost year after year
after year.
And of course the lack of technological development in agriculture,
it causes situations like this one.
The temperature has got hotter.
So there are more insects in the fruit and grain. I don't understand it,
but if it continues,
we're going to have many problems in growing food and feeding ourselves.
Dawa chairing Bhutanese farmer from pero.
We'll just wait one second.
There's also a bond in the land of the thunder dragon. Well, fortunately not.
Bruton.
Also has its strong points. Over the last few years, things have improved.
The economy has grown. The government invests a good chunk of that tourist tax.
When we're talking about enter preserving and developing its tourist
attractions.
And of course there is a field in which this country could become a power.
We're talking about hydro power, the cheapest energy in the world,
and one which Bhutan already.
Exports.
Thanks to its impressive mountainous geography.
Bhutan is a Mecca of hydroelectric power in the region.
Most of the power produced is exported to India and the revenue from these
exports alone already accounts for almost 30% of the government's revenue and
14% of its gross domestic product.
And other words hydro-power is potentially the blue gold of this country.
And let's not forget the Bhutanese neighbors are huge countries that are
devouring energy constantly between India and nearby Bangladesh alone.
We are talking about more than 1.6 billion people.
By way. Most of the hydro.
Plants have been built by Indian companies.
India is in fact Bhutan's greatest ally with politically and above all else
economically, to give you an idea,
India is the country from which almost 90% of imports come.
And as the destination of more than 80% of Bhutan's exports,
very few countries in the world have as dependent a relationship as Bhutan's
towards its Southern neighbor. But this leads us to a key question.
Are we missing someone in this equation? Many of you may be thinking,
so where is China in all this.
[Inaudible].
On paper. It kind of seems like a no brainer for China's expansion strategy.
Here's a pure country in development with a significant lack of both investment
and infrastructure. I don't really know.
It kind of seems like the type of place where China would like to invest and
sink his closet. Doesn't it.
And the truth is that Chinese investments and aid have grown in recent years,
especially when it comes to health and education. However,
the kingdom of Bhutan remains faithful to its ND and ally.
So faithful has even come to reject.
Beijing's offered to be part of the new silk roads,
the gigantic infrastructure network promoted by Zhang pink.
And although the Chinese presence is gradually being noticed. For example,
it was a Chinese company that built the gigantic Buddha door, Denver statue,
a statue covered in gold leaf that has become one of the symbols of the country.
Chinese presence today remains mostly in the background
Beyond their spiritual or economic peculiarities.
There are some things in supposedly country of happiness that are never talked
about. It's the other site of the romantic Emily and kingdom. Let's take a look.
The most unknown side.
The image of the Butan conveys to the world is that of a tranquil peaceful and
above all Placid country.
And I do like Buddhist kingdom and the heart of the Himalayas.
And to some extent it may be just that. However,
as we always say here on visual politic, all that glitters is not always.
Cool.
And as we have seen, Bhutan is a very poor country and that's not,
it's only downstate.
What would you think if I were to tell you that Bhutan is actually a country
where there has been in some way remains institutional persecution and
discrimination of ethnic minorities? Well,
you probably won't be surprised to hear that that is more or less what happened
to the lot Sampa and Nepalese speaking, ethnic minorities.
I see.
So here's the deal since 1988 and throughout the 1990s tens and tens of
thousands of lots of Amper people have been stripped of their Brittany's
documentation and turned into stateless persons,
an estimated 800,000 to 100,000 people ended up displaced in refugee camps in
Nepal and India comes where they were for nearly two decades before they get
immigrate to other countries in 2017,
the us state department and a human rights report on Bhutan noted that the
country still has Nepalese speaking, political prisoners.
The government refuses to reinstate many of the refugees who have claimed
Bhutanese citizens.
Are you sure you're talking about Bhutan, the kingdom of the thunder dragon,
the Adeleke country whose government supposedly makes and measures its decisions
in terms of general happiness. Well, yes.
And the question is where does this hatred of ethnic minorities from,
Well,
that may be surprising as something that has a lot to do with its obsession,
with maintaining national tradition and culture at all costs.
You may never have thought about it, but in a way,
Bhutan is one of the most nationalistic countries in the world.
So in order to get rid of them,
the Bhutanese government determined that the lot Sampa were no more than
newcomers, something like illegal immigrants,
despite this ethnic group having lived in Southern Bruton's since at least 1620.
So the fact is that the group's expulsion came under the boots and these
citizenship laws of 1958 and 1985.
So although many lots of people were given nationality in 1958,
many others were unable to prove definitively that they recited in Bhutan before
that year,
I conditioned to the later in 1985 law rigidly demanded and applied in a totally
arbitrary manner. Think about it logically for just one moment,
imagine that you are in a family of peasants who live under the poverty
threshold and you basically live on whatever you can grow from the lunch.
You probably can't read or write,
and there are no records of ownership of your lens or anything like that.
So I want arts, do you show that you've been living in that place for decades?
If the testimony of your neighbors doesn't count for anything,
this is the situation more or less that many members of this ethnicity
experienced.
They went from being born and living in Bhutan to becoming an illegal immigrants
and being forcibly expelled from their own country.
Something that obviously had consequence
Expulsion of tens of thousands of member of the lots AMPA ethnic group led to an
ethnic military conflict that ended up with a confrontation of the Royal Bhutan
army with armed members of this social group. According to the government,
just two members of the security forces lost their lives. Of course,
from unofficial sources,
the figure rises to at least 300 deaths and more than 2000 deaths.
So.
Visual politics, Bhutan's political system as a peculiar thing.
And today it doesn't much resemble a consolidated democracy.
Yeah.
The idea the first democratic elections were in 2007 and the first government
elected entirely by the ballot box and a free election did not arrive until 2011
before then basically what was,
there was an absolute monarchy and the purest style of medieval feudalism.
And of course,
is this a recent history of authoritarianism that explains that in many areas of
politics and society,
respect for human rights or political and social freedoms are not a priority.
Listen up.
Many of the authoritarian structures built by King Jimmy,
the fourth are still working. Monarchy has not yielded significant power.
This system combined civil liberties with political authoritarianism,
academic doorbell resolve in his book,
the Royal semi authoritarian democracy of Bhutan.
Anyway, as you can see,
we're talking about a country strictly controlled by the government and the
Royal family, a country, to which, for example,
television did not arrive until it was legalized in 1999.
We're speaking for better or worse of what's perhaps one of the least
influential countries in globalization throughout the world,
a country with medieval structures that with a carefully trained focus on its
natural charms and above all the invention of the gross national happiness index
have made it an epicenter of happiness,
peace and cultural and environmental conservation in the collective imagination.
However,
the reality as so often happens as a little different from that of those.
Ed lanes.
Yet in recent years, the country has embraced a democratic system.
Its economy has grown and its openness to the world is greater than ever before.
And of course the thunder dragon kingdom is and will remain one of the most
enigmatic and captivating places in the world.
So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you do,
you can hit the little button down there if you want to get updates.
And whenever our new video is coming up and don't forget to subscribe for all of
our brand new content.
Also don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided all the vocals in this episodes that were not my dulcet tones.
Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always see you next time.
I want to learn more about politics and world affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice.
Come check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on
Apple or Google play or your favorite pod.
Gotcha.